[Music]
welcome back at 7 30 to cbs this morning
across the country millions of americans
are
missing appointments for their second
vaccine dose that's according to the cdc
more than 5 million of us about 8
percent of appointment takers
had missed their second pfizer or
modernity doses
as of early april and the cdc says that
second shot
is critical in helping protect people
from the virus our adriana diaz is at a
vaccination site outside
chicago's wrigley field adriana good
morning to you what do you see there
good morning well tony it's not usually
this quiet outside of wrigley but it's
still pretty early
here's what's happening here later this
week at a vaccine clinic in this
building next to wrigley they're going
to start accepting walk-ins so people
without appointments to really encourage
people to get vaccinated
but as you mentioned there are millions
of people who are not getting that
second dose
and that's creating concern that we're
going to lose the ground we've gained
against the virus
39 year old danielle lee is an
occupational therapist
living in southern california with her
family at first she wasn't sure if she'd
get the coveted vaccine at
all because she says she's had adverse
reactions to vaccines in the past
how did you decide to finally get that
first dose when you had your
reservations
it was almost like a i guess maybe an
emotional decision i think it was a
combination
of you know i've people's people maybe a
little bit peer pressure
as well like you see other people doing
it she only had mild symptoms after her
first pfizer dose but she's not sure
she'll get her second she's frustrated
after learning she may need a booster
and
annual shot and is still worried about
side effects
danielle are you are you more afraid of
bad reactions to the second dose
or possibly getting covered to be honest
i'm more worried about bad reactions to
the second dose
she's not alone according to a report in
the new york times the reason people are
skipping second shots
include issues with second dose
appointments people already feeling
protected with just one shot
or if they felt sick after the first
dose side effects that last for weeks or
months
after a vaccine are probably not due to
the vaccine you need to see the doctor
and make sure there's not something else
going on what can cause lingering
ongoing problems for many many months
is covet dr emily landon is an
infectious disease specialist at the
university of chicago medicine
she said people are considered
unvaccinated until they've had
both shots in the way that the vaccine
is supposed to work
is the first shot is sort of like your
body being told
here's a picture of a spike protein this
is what you're looking for
and you need to take care of it if you
see it and
oftentimes our bodies react the same way
that we react and they say okay got it
sounds good but then the second shot is
like a practice run
it's uh sort of tricks your body and
says here's that spike protein again
and your body jumps into action and it
does everything that it needs to do to
fight off that spike protein
and that creates that big boost in
antibodies that last longer
what risk is someone taking by possibly
not getting the second dose
not getting your second shot means
you're kind of giving up on your
immunity and you may be at risk for
covid as soon as a few
months after that first vaccine secondly
you have
way lower immunity to all of the
variants that are the predominant things
that are circulating right now
if not enough people get the second shot
could we possibly regress i mean could
we not reach hurt immunity could we go
back to square one
or two absolutely this covid
is not gone danielle's second dose
appointment is this friday
but she's still not sure if she'll go is
it going to be a game time decision
i'll probably in my mind tell me or tell
myself you know you can make that
decision when you wake up that way like
the pressure is off
of me what if too many people don't get
their second dose
and we don't stamp out this virus yeah
no i i think that's a
very valid concern and i thought about
that and thought okay i don't want to be
a part of the problem but i i think
that's a very valid point that
if we all just are kind of half vast
like that's not going to
help the situation danielle told us
another reason she's hesitant about the
second dose is because of the johnson
and johnson vaccine pause
even though she got pfizer that's still
raising concerns for her about safety
now dr landon couldn't have reiterated
more strongly that the risk from covid
far outweighs any risk from a rare side
effect from one of the vaccines
anthony yeah let's underline that
adriana again thank you and as we heard
dr landon say
you're not fully vaccinated until you've
had that second shot
and it can't you can't get a kick from
it i felt it but that's telling you that
it's doing its job
yeah that kick is temporary it lasts a
day
pretty much that's it and there's no
peace of mind if you don't get that
second one
and you've already exposed yourself to
what are your whatever your worries were
about getting a shot in the first place
you already got one shot you're halfway
there
the first one as the doctor said is
really the setup for the second shot
which is what really does the job
yeah i know it's such a personal just
decision and it's but it's so scary for
so many people but it's so
important yeah that's the only way we're
going to get out of this
the only way